Film Courage: In under 5 minutes can you give
us the best screenwriting advice?
Gavin Michael Booth, Writer/Director/Cinematographer:
Be different.
Just because you read a book on screenwriting,
don’t follow that exact format.
Read every screenplays.
Read every screenplay you can from amateur
to professional.
Movies you’ve watched, get those screenplays,
especially from sites like (I don’t even
know who still exists) but Drew’s Script-o-rama
or anywhere that houses screenplays but especially
if you live in LA there’s stores that sell
them.
I try to get early drafts to scripts and understand
the changes that they’ve made to production.
I think the more you see the evolution of
how writing is changing over the years, how
character development and dialogue and looking
at all of the different…because there isn’t
one set format for writing a screenplay.
There used to be but not so much anymore.
I just feel like the more you read, you just
filter through this works for what I’m doing,
this doesn’t work, when you just see the
way that people use description, it’s just
practice.
For indie filmmakers, don’t shoot your first
draft.
Your first draft is not perfect unless you
are the next Robert Town or just somebody
who’s got this amazing ability to…Kravin
Smythe of CLARKS (but I bet that wasn’t
even his first draft).
Just because you finish it and doesn’t mean
it’s perfect, so get feedback.
Have table reads, listen to the advice people
give you even if you don’t like it.
You are always going to have to fight for
some things and you don’t have to take everyone’s
advice.
You will never not learn something that you
didn’t think of or didn’t see as being
a problem in your script the more people you
ask to give you feedback.
Of course you will want to do something weird
and wild that people won’t understand and
that’s okay you don’t have to change but
you have to rewrite and rewrite and rewrite
to get that feedback because it’s so important
to shape…there is no way that any one writer
can have all the answers and bang out a perfect
screenplay without that guidance and help.
Film Courage: Did you ever think about what
your life would be like if you hadn’t have
gone to that Third Eye Blind concert?
Gavin: I’d probably be shooting wedding
videos in Windsor, Ontario [Canada].
Yes, I’m not sure…I think I’ve got the
fight in me and I’ve wanted to make movies
for a long time and I’ve always figured
out a way.
It could be that it’s nothing you can’t
think about right?
Because it’s that sliding doors effect of
the Gwines Paltros movie of the BUTTERFLY
RIPPLES.
If I’d gone a more traditional way would
I be making more experimental movies I’m
making now?
Probably not.
Maybe I’d have more success working in the
studio system or for television networks but
it would be wildly different.
And that just taught me to start sneaking
into everything as long as I wasn’t breaking
the law.
I met my wife sneaking into a party at the
Toronto Film Festival.
I definitely would not have done that if it
had not worked previously so successful with
bands and I used to sneak into events where
I knew that I could meet people that couldn’t
potentially read scripts or take a meeting
with.
So yes…it would be wildly different.